number one reason why we don't ask for  help is because it shows weakness you  feel like if if i ask this person for  help why would i ask for help i'm strong  i don't need your help i can do it on my  own why would i ask you a question like  this because we're worried because we're  gonna seem weak number two perfectionist  perfectionists have a hard time asking  for help because they don't think  anybody can do the job as good as they  can so they have a very hard time having  people around them that help them  because like let me just do myself you  know what i'm just gonna do this on my  own you guys can't figure this stuff out  i'm gonna do it on my own that's a  perfectionist right and if you have that  personality you're gonna build a very  small team because no one around you is  gonna be eventually learning how to do  their job because you keep doing  everyone's job yourself number three  you're afraid because if you ask and you  say hey john